c'est un scandale qui fragilise le
gouvernement péruvien depuis une semaine
les médias révèlent dans quelles
conditions on était mené les essais
cliniques du vaccin chinois sinopharm
dans le pays
en plus de l'échantillon de 12000
personnes choisies pour les premières
injections des centaines de privilégiés
ont été vaccinés contre le coc vie 19
dès le mois d'octobre 2020 l'ancien
président martin vizcarra ferait partie
de cette liste de patients ayant
bénéficié de ce traitement de faveur
également visée par ces révélations les
ministres de la santé et des affaires
étrangères qui ont été poussés à la
démission en début de semaine dans un
pays qui déplore plus de 90000 mort du
co vie 19 les représentants du personnel
soignant ne décolère pas c'est un
sentiment d'indignation
on se sent trahie notamment par l'ancien
président et l'ancien ministre qui nous
a dit cinq jours avant le scandale
qu'elle n'avait pas été vaccinés
quelle serait la dernière à être
vaccinés ils ont préféré assurer leur
propre vie sachant que leur exposition
minimes ils ne se soucient pas de
l'exposition qui est la nôtre en ce
moment en première ligne beaucoup
d'entre nous ne figure pas sur la liste
du personnel qui devraient être vaccinés
et c'est grave
ces révélations en cascade ont en effet
dévastateur
à moins de deux mois de l'élection
présidentielle face à la colère
grandissante d'une partie de la
population le gouvernement tente de
jouer la carte de la transparence
lundi le président par intérim a rendu
publique la liste des 487 personnes à
avoir été vacciné et ce jeudi une
enquête gouvernementale a été ouverte
fort malmenée lança véhémence ton destin
et sa nounou
savons pas où se trouvent les doses
manquantes néanmoins la commission
denquête va demander ces informations et
je suis sûr que les autorités
compétentes auquel nous avons demandé
d'agir et de procéder conformément à la
loi
je fais référence aux contrôleurs du
ministère public et au procureur général
de l'état vont demander les informations
dès que nous les aurons nous le ferons
évidemment savoir si les scandales
autour des politiques de vaccination se
multiplient toujours en amérique du sud
des personnalités politiques en
argentine et en équateur aurait
bénéficié de passe droit pour se faire
vacciner